greg one of the things that's uh just
blowing me away right now while we've
been on this conversation uh the news
just broke that the fdic chairman said
that the banks and the oversight of fdic
are working to come up with a framework
so that banks can hold bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and also trying to
figure out how they would use it as
collateral hold it on the balance sheet
et cetera the
molly
holy moly seriously i swear what what's
your thought process in terms of uh u.s
banks if they start to hold bitcoin to
use it as actual collateral it's the
it's the pristine collateral of the
world like that is why i think the us
has been served up a gift by china by
china pushing bitcoin mining to the
western countries this is a gift for me
and my children and for you and your i
know you don't have kids i i don't think
you do but anyway at the end of the day
your future kids right this is why we
need to take this gift and embrace it
because you will have a store of value
pristine
savings account and you will still have
the us dollar
reserve currency or checking account for
the world and together this these dual
networks will allow the us to remain
supreme uh
freedom and it will
supreme economy of a global economy this
is what the world needs this is
certainly what canada needs canada needs
the us because you're our sec we're your
second largest trading partner and you
are our most important trading partner i
need that for my kids so i love the usa
i don't ever want it to fail this is
good for business it's even better for
freedom and i just want to summarize
with one with one thing here i do
believe there will be a time when energy
oil and natural gas is priced in bitcoin
i think vlad putin is thinking of that
right now okay and to do that he's
basically think how does he get out of
the petrol dollar he doesn't want uh to
hold us treasuries in reserve those are
fiat contracts that are programmed to
debase what if he took bitcoin and
payment for his energy
wow then he's starting to build up a
reserve of the most pristine collateral
ever digital energy
being paid for natural resource energy i
think it's inevitable i'm an engineer
like sailor i'm just playing the odds
and then if that happens
five percent of 200 or of 900 trillion
quickly becomes 20
of 200 trillion and all of a sudden my
price target for bitcoin isn't 2 million
it's something like 20 million a coin
play the odds guys this is the race
track this is how you manage risk talk
to me about how uh energy gets priced in
bitcoin like what would that
sequentially look like
all it takes is one of the big uh
non-opec guys like russia to uh just say
hey why don't you start paying me a
bitcoin world you can either pay me in
bitcoin or you can pay me in the u.s
dollars and i'm going to buy bitcoin but
it'll be here's my price of oil in u.s
dollars and here's my price of oil in
bitcoin and what if it's a 10 discount
to get it in bitcoin
i don't know pretty smart people in the
world will say well okay here's here's
your bitcoin vlad
and all of a sudden it becomes a basis
where there is a market much like you
know you have brent nor see oil trading
against west texas crude it's different
markets trade on different uh at
different prices for different reasons
and again as an engineer why wouldn't it
be that way
why would you be selling beautiful
natural resource energy for useless fiat
dollars in the long term fiat is very
valuable in the short term what does it
do it facilitates international trade
it it
eliminates the need to barter but what
it is not good at is storing value over
time and space that is what bitcoin is
so it just takes a step away